the Joe Rogan experience and everything
else with that and you know it you
brought up an interesting point - not to
keep going down the rabbit hole but uh
the other thing that I thought really
interesting was when you look at waste
components I feel like we're not maybe
looking at that as much as as we should
be when we're talking about trying to
feed a bunch of people's like well maybe
we should start with what we're throwing
away that we wouldn't have - oh yeah and
I think like at first I just thought
like well you know there's a lot of food
thrown away at restaurants there's a lot
of stuff that's thrown away just because
it doesn't meet standards for like the
grocery store it's like let's start
there and I actually had asked dr.
Schindler about that he actually did a
study with some of his grad students
where they looked at I think they took
30 white-tailed deer and they they
processed it down to like the very last
potential calorie to find out how much
is wasted even in like a you know a deer
that say you go and you shoot a deer and
then you could take it to the the
process and get it all done he said it
was between I think was between like 13
to 30 days worth of human nutrition that
gets wasted you know a single
white-tailed deer whoa so like well
here's the problem with that idea a
waste is only if you do something with
it if you leave it in the field there's
no waste right but if you just killed a
deer that it's not it just left it there
there's no waste it's you're feeding
animals right I mean they're going to
absolutely destroy that thing it's gonna
be gone in a short period of time
including the bone so will delete the
bones and if they don't eat the bones
the bones will eventually deteriorate
and become a part of the soil this is
what happens when animals die sure so I
guess maybe the way to look at them is
like what are we if we're looking to
just if our objective is to feed as many
people as possible and we're maximizing
the amount of nutrients we can acquire
from a specific thing like we're leaving
a lot on the table or we're giving a lot
to different areas like different
animals and things that are going well
we're doing it wrong you know we're
putting our waste in bags and we're
throwing it into the ground fills I mean
landfills
have you seen they did this aerial study
of Los Angeles they're trying to find
out where most of the methane comes from
they were trying to go it's [ __ ]
landfills man landfills are disgusting
and this is not how it's supposed to be
it's supposed to be animals are supposed
to have access to what's left over
I mean this is what would happen if a
bear killed a moose all right if a bear
killed a moose it's going to consume a
big portion of the body and then it's
going to leave whatever is left and then
rodents and vultures and and then
eventually insects and bacteria are
going to break it down and this is a
natural cycle of life for animals this
is how it's supposed to be what we do is
we take it we cut it up we eat some of
it we throw some of it away we put that
in a plastic bag we zip tie it we did a
[ __ ] hole in the ground and we throw
that bag in there it's not it's
ludicrous
yeah it's we know better we do know
better we understand the whole process
of these things breaking down in the
wild and what happens to them we
understand that there's animals that
their entire diet consists of eating
animals that other animals have killed
and they leave some of it behind that's
we're supposed to leave it behind it's
supposed to be a part of the whole cycle
of life we were supposed to compost all
these things are supposed to be natural
we you know when I was a kid my mom and
my stepdad were part of this cooperative
farm thing and we started composting and
I'm we didn't do it for very long
because we eventually wind up moving and
we stopped we stopped being a part of
this thing but I thought it was really
interesting cuz I was a little kid I
think like oh I never thought of that
before you take your food waste and you
separate it from like paper uh-huh I'll
give your paper waste and then you have
like leftover Tomatoes or something like
that and all that would go into one
specific bin and that bin would go into
this big thing it was like it was made
with like chicken wire and leaves and
you had a lid over it and like it was a
wood box and you would throw everything
in there and it would all sort of rot in
compost and then you would take that
stuff and you would use it in the garden
and this is this is how composting is
done this is how fertilizer is made and
this is what you're supposed to do yeah
this is like small-scale regenerative
farming and what we're doing is [ __ ]
as we take our food we put in [ __ ]
bags we zip tie it shut and we chuck it
in the ground it's dumb it's a really
dumb way of
doing things I just feel like that is
something that we could really leverage
at the educational level like yeah we've
got schools where we were housing these
kids and like you know one of the
biggest hurdles I think is like we got
them indoors sitting in desks for seven
eight hours a day and then we what why
not get them out and learn that and do
that and we have these mini little like
regenerative areas sure then you learn
it and then it doesn't get forgotten
when you're an adult as easily well
we're so enamored with this idea of
working you know we're so enamored with
this idea of getting a job
we're so enamored with this idea of the
structure of civilization as it stands
in 2019 is the way to go so we're
teaching kids how to complete this the
this life that they're born into the way
it's established for their parents the
way it's established for their
neighborhood get in your car drive to
work work all day come home you know eat
what you can throw the rest of the
garbage go back to work in the morning
and this is nonsense this is not how you
have to do you don't you don't have to
do anything there's a bunch of different
ways to live this life and there's only
a hundred years if you're lucky so this
thing that we're setting up we're
setting up kids to essentially be as
miserable as everybody else before them
doing the exact same thing that
everybody else has done like maybe you
can get lucky like I have been or like
you've been and you find something that
you actually enjoy doing then you get
lucky like oh my god
you know Zak found a job that he really
loves and he got really good at it and
now he actually has joy in what he does
but there's there's a lot of different
places in this this country alone where
you can live and you could do things in
a non-traditional manner and you can get
by and you probably be healthier and
happier than someone that gets stuck in
the same goddamn Civilization cycle this
industrialized cycle sure that we're all
in and we don't teach kids that well we
teach kids is here's history here's math
get your SATs in get the score go to the
college that you want get a job and this
is the the standard path that seems to
be rewarded and this is what and if you
say well I'm gonna drop out and find
myself oh good luck loser
you know you're gonna [ __ ] up your life
you know what are you doing man you
don't even go into college Jesus Christ
like and it's very unfortunate that we
have this incredibly rigid system and
and it really makes people feel like
made me feel like a failure I didn't fit
into the system I just because of I have
a DD or whatever emotional issues
whatever I had I just could not sit
still in class and concentrate I had way
too much [ __ ] energy this is just this
was just not for me I was twiddling my
thumbs and tapping the floor and looking
at the clock and a critic like yes when
that [ __ ] thing hit I was gone and I
didn't want to do home I'd literally
didn't do any homework my entire high
school career I didn't do anything I
just got by being smart enough to pass
tests by learning what I learned in
class and not putting in any [ __ ]
extra effort I just wanted to get out
and I found something that I was good at
I figured it out I found I got lucky
that I did that but for a lot of people
they just lived these lives of
frustration you know and they never do
find and they're not taught to find a
thing and there's also I think there's a
great satisfaction to working on
something that you enjoy whether it's
working with your hands or working on
something that's creative and working
with the land you know you talk to
people that run their own little organic
farms like I know this couple that runs
an organic farm and man when they talk
about their their food they talk about
the vegetables they grow and the stuff
they grow they like beam excited about
it they're excited is it's a natural
there's there's a there's natural
there's a gravity that we have towards
that it's a natural human reward to be
able to cultivate your own food if you
didn't make a salad out of some stuff
that you grew yourself man that feels
amazing it really does and there's
people that could be making a living
doing that and they're never encouraged
to do so and they might be way happier
than selling insurance yeah yeah I'd
know I agree I think I can feed other
people too man that's the other thing
like if you could figure out a way to
run an organic garden and you do compost
you don't use pesticides you do
everything organic and everything is
regenerative and you actually can feed
people oh my god wait how good would you
pretty satisfying yes yeah I would think
I would think really satisfying him it's
not for everybody but it's got to be for
somebody yeah and they're not being no
one's teaching you that right yeah you
have to be one of those outside the box
thinkers because schools essentially set
up for scale right it's got a set up for
you got 500 kids you got to turn them
into not losers yeah good 500 kids to
not be a loser well just standard path
you know like this like standard
American diet so exist entered American
education these six standard paths that
will work for X amount of people you get
ten people seven of them won't be losers
if you just shove them into this machine
and pump them out in this [ __ ] form
yeah it's a bummer uh-huh we're now here
we're getting education advice from the
ultra marathon runner yeah but you're
good gotta get education advice from
blood was the teacher for five years so
well it's also you're you're a
successful guy at an unusual thing you
know you found a thing that you really
excel at that you actually enjoy yeah
and that is for so many people the
ultimate goal of life like if you can
make a lot of money in this life
but you will not be as happy it's really
contrary to like capitalist ideas like
we were taught to think that the more
money you make them to happier you'll be
that's definitely not true but you will
make more money if you're happier with
what you do which is sounds like a
contradiction but it's not you'll excel
and if you're excelling you'll
profitable obviously there's some things
that you can Excel out that are just
there's no [ __ ] way to make a lot of
money as a bowler you know if you like
I'm really in a bowling well you're kind
of [ __ ] because it's just one of those
things that nobody gives a [ __ ] about
find something else you're interested in
- yeah yeah be nice you found something
actually paid the bills but if you can
find something that you enjoy you'll
have an infinitely happier life it's
just you you can do that you just have
to find those you have to explore those
things and I think that's where we
failed kids
we failed kids and giving them this
landscape of possibilities that actually
does exist I think there's a landscape
of possibilities for what you can do and
everyone is gently I don't want to be an
ultramarathon runner man right if you
and I are competing I'm [ __ ] okay
I'm not going to win I'm not gonna Excel
built like a chimp
I'm not I'm not the guy that's supposed
to be running 200 miles it's just your
realm and it's also it's not what I
don't desire to do that conversely if
you had to become a stand-up comedian
you'd probably like well [ __ ] this I
don't want to do any thinking about
things that's funny and the first time
you bomb you're like what am I doing
with my life and it's everybody has a
different personality and these
different personalities and these
different interests and desires they
take different paths and I think we need
to open that up to people more and and
just sort of in some way encourage
people to seek more to seek to genuinely
try to find the things that interest you
maybe you should be a fly fishing guide
you know maybe you should be a guy who
makes homemade mugs out of exotic
hardwood you know maybe you know maybe
you're a knife maker maybe you're a
person who maybe should make [ __ ]
dream catchers I don't know don't make
dream catchers does anybody really like
dream catchers those like something you
buy and then you put it on the wall and
you go what the [ __ ] am i doing am i
pretending I'm in the Native American or
something
but there's things you can do man you
just have to find that thing and I think
that's so hard for people and that's why
people when they find someone like
yourself that's doing this unusual
unorthodox thing and you're extremely
successful at it
that becomes so attractive to people to
hear your story yeah and I think yeah I
it's I would have never guessed I'd be
doing what I'm doing now ten years ago
it's yes equally surprising to me I
think sometimes but it you know it is it
is interesting when you think about just
where you thought you would maybe be and
then where you end up and all that stuff
in-between and ultimately I think if you
I think you want to be be smart about
stuff like I didn't necessarily just
quit my job and say I'm gonna be an
ultra marathon runner you kind of have
like a few different options available
or you just keep options open to like
for me personally I like to coach too so
I'm gonna do some of that and that helps
supplement things and then you know
podcasting has always been a fun thing
to do so historically I'd always go on
podcast and then a couple years ago it
was like well if it's this much fun to
go on them it must be fun to do them too
so you know starting these other
when people start kind of really
exploring where their curiosities are
you find these different avenues to and
they just kind of snowballs a little bit
as opposed to being maybe you start out
making the dreamcatcher and then you
become something else right that's right
you just get really in the feathers
[Applause]